hey guys i'm ryan right and all this
would be crazy
we got recommended by posted a tweet out
of facebook post two about which videos
we should watch today and we came across
this one title that i was like okay i'm
doing that one Thank You Alexander Oh
Jeffrey sweet Alexander O'Neal Jeffrey
O'Neal Jeff O'Neal Jeffrey's and the
video is the rap battle Perry I love rap
battles rapping is is so [ __ ] cool of
me ever since eight mile high I've been
so been to them so yeah let's just get
to it
no we add as prompt I'm rapping let's go
ahead and get into it we got our
Challenger over here t-bone to to follow
my net food T steak let's go ahead get
it to our main man the champion himself
no need for introductions
first of all I'm not a rapper that's
where to get it to this little boy good
luck everybody know what I'd do heads
you know I go yup
tails hey I'll go first give it a try
when the call comes a super hot he goes
first check me out check I broke up with
my ex girl here's a number psych that's
the way number you see you I spit them
sweet dollar tea from McDonough I drink
that super hot fire I Spit that two and
a half me I watched that
I'm not a rabbit
glasses jacket shirt color glasses I can
shoot me you calling back red I'll call
me super hot boy honey degrees leather
jacket cuz I'm super hot boy
not a rapper to super hot I'm not a rat
I'm not all right so I got lost in a
train of thought if this all that
goodness I just heard go ahead and get
this crowd pumped up just a little bit
more if you can't teach take t-bone
there is a right producer is this what
they put me up against super hot I never
heard of you I'm looking at him like is
he stupid I'm about to murder you my
cool and waited
rook serving you I'm like Shaq I get
battle and then his backyard save 30 Wow
shut your girl always confuse my child
with the spoon ha yes tall enough so she
can ride nice I got the tool book for
you I keep the merchandise about the
shop thank you they told me I had to
battle they set up might not to be this
much that setup good I don't know all
right go ahead and get it to a champion
look look him pulling my pants for this
one pull them up good first of all yeah
I'm not too friend
it'll stop looking at me mmm said my boy
I'm not a rapper so stop rapping now
really a mr. Salinger baby why I check
me out check me out and kill it all for
me
that's innocent I'm not the English mass
whole career what color not around
what career boom BAM oh not about boom
pow
mr. Spock time wrapping you see what
goes down we're done here so what
champion this one
said what I don't know that's over six
million views Wow that was readily
disappointing as it was at the same time
I kind of love that guy
because I didn't say much at all but was
able to get us laughing at first
coordinate it started off like okay this
is good this is building then after a
while I'm like they're just doing the
same [ __ ] like over and over and over
again like it was a basic thing of he
says something that's not rapping and
then crowd loses their [ __ ] right I
don't like this once they did a good job
at by the way yeah I mean what they did
was they were good at but yeah that one
joke I got bored of it like pretty early
on when you beat it over and over and
over here's the thing though is that
they had really good comedic timing and
although they kind of wore it out it was
still good when they used it I just
think it could have been much better I
didn't like the jump cuts either yeah I
wonder what um program they were using
cuz it wasn't very fluid at all when
you're doing the rapping bits and stuff
and like they're supposed to be coming
up with this stuff on the top of their
head when they do a jump cut I'm like
well they cut the camera probably mm-hmm
you know like yeah they did a retake you
know like and the idea of this to make
it funny is you have to make it look
authentic whenever I saw the jump cuts
in the middle of them doing their bit
for like a freestyle they ruined the
flow it ruins the flood the rosey energy
ruins the excitement yeah and like it
was funny at first but for a four minute
and 48 minute 42nd and forty eight
second video I thought I was like a
little long for this bit it didn't
escalate into anything no it was like it
just stayed stagnant into this one joke
like the only thing escalated was the
crowd's reaction you could have added
background music I mean the thing with
that is it's such a minut detail but it
can add so much energy without even
trying Oh totally yeah you know it could
add so much to it it's a rap battle you
can even have someone beatboxing you
know some
even doing a shitty beatboxing would
have made this video better I'm shocked
this video it must be just the title of
the video that got a huge battle parody
the parody is like oh he's not really
rapping but the crowds losing their [ __ ]
yeah one guy tries to rap and no one
really cares I think it's more along the
lines of a short than a parody it's not
actually a parody of anything I just was
watching and I was like rap battle
parody I get the one joke mm-hmm but it
could have been so much more like the
things are saying the dialogue it could
it could have escalated in some fashion
oh yeah but there's no escalation I feel
like this is a video that is funny to
the guys involved in the video and their
friends you it's a joke yeah I feel like
it'll make them crack up thanks
Alexander hey Google Jeffries thanks for
recommending this viral video sorry I
didn't quite enjoy it as much as you
probably hoped I would listen did if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out Elissa be crazies channel
there's a lot of vlogs and challenges
and such and she's prepping for the new
year so yeah check that out and because
this is a long video we're not gonna do
shout outs today but we're gonna be
continuing them in the next upcoming
videos so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shout outs keep a lookout
for our reaction review videos or you
can earn yourself a shout out by saying
something fun and interesting and we
will shout you out and you will be
rewarded because we are opinionated the
reward system here it doesn't work like
a regular reward I don't know be work
this rap battle sucked I just didn't
give a [ __ ] I sit here and I say oh
shucks I mean these guys had a bunch of
luck they got a video that went so viral
but I don't know what to do it's like an
internal battle for me to wonder how did
this become so popular I mean it just
seems like a failure
rap battle yeah whatever and then the
camera cut just now so now if I continue
it's not it's gonna look like [ __ ]